nothing came along that made me feel
confident of setting aside my initial
gut reaction
on the contrary all of the information
that was coming from official sources
was intensifying my feeling of threat
and because it so quickly became a
slanging match
we were suddenly in the playground being
bullied
by big boys and girls
and i thought this is so inappropriate
this is a this is an emergency facing
the entire world and within minutes
the best tool at the disposal
has been calling people names
if there's no if there's no credible
readily understood argument that can be
made in a low calm voice to explain to
me why i ought to take a part
if that's all right if it's already at
the point where they just have to say if
you don't do i'm going to hit you
and if that doesn't work i'm going to
hit you harder
i've never got beyond knowing that
that's why something is wrong
they don't have something that they can
readily sell
it's not something anyone would want to
buy
so that they had to force it on people
because it's there's something hinky
about it
and i've never
once i realized that once i felt that
i've never been persuaded otherwise
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast splish splash we are podcasting
from bath and i am here with neil oliver
and i could not be more delighted to be
sitting in proximity to you sir
welcome thank you so much for making
time for me it's beautiful here today it
is beautiful here today and i have to
say there's something that i just i i'm
not going to be able to really
describe it um but i know from talking
to you
yesterday that you are experiencing
something similar
many of us have been on a journey that
we started on separately something set
us off something alerted us that things
were not
right in the world and
most people who had that experience
didn't say anything but some of us did
and what came back was an incredible
onslaught
now that was difficult to take but what
also happened is that we found each
other and we discovered that there are
other people in the world um some of
them
quite remarkable
and
that you know we effectively joined
forces so i i remember the moment that i
first became aware of you
you are
a broadcaster on gbn news
here in britain
and i
remember
listening to
what i think i have to describe as a
soliloquy it was very unusual for
television it was just a beautifully
crafted extremely
insightful
description of where we are in uh the
most beautiful accent i've perhaps ever
heard and i just thought
wow how did i not know that this person
existed well that's that's lovely to
hear from you brett that's that's very
i'll i'll take that with me um
it has been the most bizarre experience
i've i've tried to come up with
analogies for it i think i i think i
returned off into the idea of it's as
though we were all on a ship and the
ship hit some sort of submerged obstacle
and sank
and we've all looked around at what's
been left floating
and so
there's someone over there and there's
someone over there and we've all kind of
gradually swung together and linked arms
amongst the floating
wreckage
and it's been it's been the most
unlikely gathering of people
people that i had never crossed paths
with many many people most people i
didn't know existed
but they've been made visible by this
event
and we have cleaved together
so it has been
simultaneously a very distressing
disorientating time but also an
amazingly
renewing
time the connections i've made in the
last couple of years
have affected me profoundly
and while i i wish that the great event
had not happened i think
i'll always be grateful for the fact
that i've met the people that i've met
on account of it
so it's been a it's been a
a curse and a blessing at the same time
i have i have the identical sense i i
still believe that we are uh in grave
danger maybe this is a brief pause you
know as the the weather gets better
um but
there i don't know what else would have
put us all in contact and i think you
know if i can
slightly hesitate about saying it but i
think that
the event by its very nature
was an incredible revealer of character
and the fact is
lots of people with
different sorts of defects failed the
test and
what that it was an intense kind of
selective event that
left therefore
a lot of people who are so diverse and
unusual and maybe that's even a
vulnerability in some ways but
lots of people who
really bring to the table an
extraordinary skill set and so even as i
you know i walk around and i feel this
kind of low level trepidation almost all
the time because i know that there are
things
uh
moving that you know our rights are
being targeted and we can't even hear
what's being said
but there is also this gathering
occurring and um
by virtue of the fact that we come from
so many different backgrounds it's it's
just delightful to encounter all these
other folks it's that it's the you know
warren buffett i think said it in
another context about you know
um you meant it financially it's when
the tide goes out that you see who's
been swimming naked
and
i think the people i expected in the
aftermath of this meteor strike as it
were
that i thought i knew who would stand up
and speak on our behalf
and i was thinking particularly i
suppose about the
journalists the silverbacks of the of
the journalistic world i thought would
this would be their moment and they
would come forward and they would say
the things that need to be said and they
would ask the questions that needed to
be asked but they were spectacularly
absent
yes and i found myself looking very good
whereas so and so where is sunshine
wouldn't you'd think that she would have
an opinion but she'd be saying something
nothing and and in that you know
you know whenever when the pilot and the
co-pilot and half the people in the
plane have eaten the bad chicken and
they come someone comes back in the
disaster movie and says well someone's
going to have to sit in the pilot's seat
you thought it's not going to be
me and then suddenly you are you're up
in the cockpit right thinking i can't
fly a plane what on earth am i doing
here i mean no one is more aware of
my incongruous presence
on gb news
talking about the things i'm talking
about and interviewing the people i'm
interviewing no one is more surprised
than me my wife looks at me across the
breakfast table and says how did this
happen to you you know you used to make
cheerful little programs about
archaeology and now you're talking to
you know whoever about about these you
know
potentially apocalyptic events how has
that happened and i just say well here
we are
this is what has happened and so then i
look around at a room like yesterday and
you encounter people like like tess lori
you know who was the organizer of the
you know the conference that we're here
for and
robert malone and adele big tree people
have been sucked into this vortex
unwillingly really and for one of the
the people that you would have imagined
would have been the characters who would
articulate all our feelings
i don't know where they are to this day
and a strange cast of characters have
had to step on stage and put on
ill-fitting costumes and just get on
with it
yeah
i think tess actually makes a
particularly uh
good she's a particularly good exemplar
of your point because
um
as you will know having talked to her
uh off camera where there's no one to
observe
she is
exactly not who you would expect to be
in this role right that's right she's
reticent of its characterologically it
is inconsistent with her that she you
know
would be so avoidant of the limelight
and you can tell
that she
she had the same she looked around where
are the people who are saying what needs
to be said there was nobody she had the
tools and so she effectively has to
inhabit this entirely different role
this very public role and um
i mean it's beautiful to watch and she
shoulders that responsibility so
marvelously and yet it's like you can
tell how strange this event must have
been to have thrust her into the
limelight there's a strange another
strangely an analogous
situation you know we've talked a lot in
terms of covert about repurposed
medicines
you know the whole ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine adventure
people have been repurposed
you know the test laurie is made was
made to do something else yeah but she
has been repurposed
and as it turns out she's
at least as good if not better at doing
what needs to be done
than perhaps a more
likely candidate
although she wouldn't have wanted it
she's been conscripted into it and she
turns out to be a really really really
good soldier
yeah but she's been pulled in from
you know a lab and now she's in the
front line but it turns out she's really
good at doing that
and who knew well
but she's been repurposed she's been
repurposed and i i i think it's a
strength in a way um
and i'm particularly struck
by
you know she did
the two most important pieces of work to
allow us to peer behind the curtain with
respect to repurposed drugs especially
iremectin and you know i hate to keep
saying that word because it's you know
such a flash point but
uh
but
she first did the meta-analysis that
allows us to calmly evaluate the net
evidence in a way that is actually quite
conservative and to see how strong the
signal is right now her meta-analysis
says one thing and then the famous hill
meta-analysis says something else right
and so that would leave most people to
wonder well all right maybe it's just
not so clear
except that then the second piece of
work was revealing why the hill meta
analysis says what it does which is
frankly corruption and fraud right she
unearthed it and she unearthed it in a
way
that uh
it's just unambiguous
now i don't know most of the audience
will probably
they might have seen the clip of her
zoom call with andrew hill where he
effectively not even effectively he
admits that he has been instructed to
change the conclusion of the paper by
unnamed authors
right and we know who they are they're
they're powerful
funders it's a it's a charity actually
but there's also a more highly produced
version that includes that clip that
places it in context have you seen it i
haven't seen that it's utterly beautiful
right it really allows you to see
what happened with andrew hill and then
you have to ask yourself the question
all right i've been told ivermectin
works i've been told it doesn't work
there's evidence both ways
what are the chances that i would find
the author of the work that says it is
not useful has been pressured
by
powerful forces to change his conclusion
if this was not a cover-up of the
utility of these repurposed drugs what
are the chances that that fraud would
have happened if it really didn't work
you wouldn't have needed a fraud no
right so
the fact that tess has done that that
she has provided us both
a sober proper mathematically rigorous
analysis on the one hand and provided us
a corrective to see what the noise that
is polluting this question what what its
fundamental nature is says you know
she's much more than a good soldier she
is really um
uh a
a brilliant contributor to a very
difficult puzzle it's the it's the
aggression
i think
that triggered me early on
it was
how rapidly
that which might reasonably have been
advice
became
coercive
instruction
backed up by real
slanderous
aggressive vitriolic shaming
rhetoric
and i thought
if if the if the people who ought to
have our best interests are in this if
they're if they really are doing it
for our you know for our good
they wouldn't need to force it
you know
if it's con if it's consensual and it
comes from a place of love it's a
different animal
than this i thought why why am i being
shouted out already i haven't done
anything wrong
i'm just i was i asked some questions
earlier on my wife and i asked questions
about vaccines which all we did at the
beginning was say
let's let's watch this
because this is all new stuff let's just
just wait and see
but waiting in c was swiftly taken away
as an option it was like
it was like fisher cut bait now and if
you don't do the right thing we're we're
coming for you
and the the
the rapidity of that how quickly it was
like that was what triggered the lizard
tail in my
amygdala or something and i thought for
the first time in my life i'm in danger
here
from people
and i know not whom but i know i'm in
danger
and i wasn't quite sure what to do fight
or flight but i knew i was and it was
the first time in my life had my body
had ever responded it was a real
physiological
response to danger
at age 53 or whatever age i was when all
this started i thought i've never felt
like this before and i just trusted it i
thought well i have to i have to pay
attention to that because that's coming
from somewhere deep and it was dr i
thought that this is not authentic
um this is there's something profoundly
wrong here i don't know what it is but
because i've identified it
physiologically i have to pay attention
this episode is sponsored by american
hartford gold
by most measures inflation is at its
highest level in four decades we all
feel it at the grocery store and the
fuel pump interest rates are soaring and
retirement accounts are in real danger
if you want to better protect your
family's future you should consider that
people have been putting wealth into
precious metals for thousands of years
the more uncertain access to other
stores of value gets the more precious
precious metals are likely to become
call american hartford gold to see how
easy it is to get started
they can show you how to protect your
savings and retirement accounts by
diversifying your portfolio with
physical gold and silver
if you're concerned that sounds a little
retro just call it analog gold and
you're back at the cutting edge
all it takes to get started is a short
phone call and they'll have physical
gold and silver delivered right to your
door or inside your ira or 401k
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an a plus rating from the
better business bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients
call them now they will give you a
percentage of your first qualifying
order back in free silver
call american hartford gold at
866-828-1111
that's 866-828-1117
or text darkhorse to 998899
again that's 866-828-1117
or text darkhorse to 998899
yeah i think um
when i hear it's very interesting to
hear your report because of course i
went through some parallel version
before i even know who you were
[Music]
the
what you were registering
was that somebody was threatening you
right it isn't even just that there was
this sudden requirement to declare a
team
it was that you were being alerted that
if you didn't
there were tools to bring you in line
there'd be consequences if you didn't do
the right thing
right and so that was unmistakable if
you were in our spot and it's also
perfectly characteristic of one of these
battles this is by far the worst one
i've ever seen but
i will say that the toolkit is pretty
familiar and
the the
you know here let me just give you this
example
heather and i got into this because
we're biologists with a generalist
toolkit we're evolutionary biologists so
we're in a position to talk a bit about
viral evolution
uh about the interaction of a vaccine
with the immune system these kinds of
issues and so it just seemed
like we had a global crisis and it made
sense to try to piece together what we
were reading and make it
intuitive for people so they could
follow what was going on and you know
there were some painful lessons early on
things that we didn't understand and
came to learn but it was it was
an invigorating process
but
i'm realizing now as
evidence emerges that we didn't have
right it's easy to miss these things i
don't even know if anybody's cataloging
them
that
the whole thing was set up not to be
understood right so for example
the idea of an mrna vaccine right you
can tell me it's an mrna and it's
packaged in lipid nanoparticles and the
lipid nanoparticles pull it into cells
because the surface of the cell is made
of lipid and chemically they will tend
to affiliate right i get that and i can
intuit okay the mrna gets into the
cytoplasm and it's going to make protein
and those proteins are going to do
something and then i can know okay one
of the things they're going to do
they all make spike protein but spike
protein has been modified so that it
lodges in the cell surface so the immune
system can see it that's pretty elegant
right
you could imagine that working
here's what they didn't tell me
they didn't tell me that they had
modified the rna too
right they modified the rna in a way
that makes it most unusual
and prevents its breakdown
now i know why they did that and it's a
worthy experiment but i wouldn't run it
on a human right you wouldn't want to
inject a modified rna into a person not
knowing what happens when the body is
faced with this thing and can't break it
down because what it means is that the
spike protein is going to continue to be
made
right
once you discover oh they screwed up
they picked the spike protein and the
spike protein actually turns out to be
cytotoxic something i've been accused is
of spreading misinformation over but
it's very clear if you look at the
actual evidence
but they've now created a template for
it that won't go away in a natural form
you know how far in are we we're like
i don't know
16 months in and we discover oh when we
said rna did we forget to tell you that
we modified one of the nucleotides
you know silly us and it's like well
we're just flying blind you know
it's it's it's the craziest
story where we have to wait to discover
these things for me as an uh
what you just said is a perfect example
for me while you are while you're
talking and explaining i i can hold on
to the
the understanding of what you meet what
you tell
the information that you're transmitting
and then when you stop talking
it starts to go it starts to go away
from me again
i can only hold on to while it's
actually happening
so as a and so because i'm a
non-scientist and i don't have that you
know
the understanding that you have as an
evolutionary biologist i just had to go
on gut
right and because and nothing and i
would have gone on gut until something
better came along but nothing
better nothing came along that made me
feel confident of setting aside my
initial gut reaction on the contrary all
of the information that was coming from
official sources was intensifying my
feeling of threat
and because it so quickly became a
slanging match
we were suddenly in the playground being
bullied by big boys and girls
and i thought this is
so inappropriate
this is a this is an emergency facing
the entire world and within minutes
the best tool at the disposal has been
calling people names
if there's no if there's no credible
readily understood argument that can be
made in a low-calm voice to explain to
me why i ought to take apart
if that's all right if it's already at
the point where they just have to say if
you don't do i'm gonna hit you
and if that doesn't work i'm gonna hit
you harder
i've never got beyond knowing that
that's why something is wrong
they don't have something that they can
readily sell
it's not something anyone would want to
buy
so that they had to force it on people
because it's there's something hinky
about it
and i've never
once i realized that once i felt that
i've never been persuaded otherwise so
it's not been scientific for me because
what i would have expected from
scientists hasn't been there either
unless and until i started making
contact with with the people that were
talking about like yourself like tess
and the people that were in that room
yesterday robert malone and all of these
other people and i thought oh my god
these are the clever people that
understand this stuff and they they feel
like me and not only do they feel like
me they can explain to me why i'm right
to feel this way
so so
on that basis
it's become strangely easy to remain
resistant
because i am persuaded
that
mine is my course of action has been the
only safe one
and it is scientific that's the thing
that i you know one of their tricks is
they convinced you that that nagging
suspicion of yours is something other
than science when the fact is from a
complex systems perspective with your
own health on the line being delivered
something this novel the right thing the
right scientific conclusion is
i don't know if that's harmful but i do
know it's not safe and so one of the
things that which is an important
distinction it's a tough one for people
because they hear that and you you say
these vaccines are unsafe and they what
do you know that we don't and the answer
is i know that you haven't
had them long enough to know what the
long-term effects are that's why they're
not safe and so
i came up with this analogy that got me
in trouble early on but i i know it's
the right one all right if you walk into
a room and there's a gun on the table
and you pick it up and you put it to
your head and you pull the trigger and
it goes click
right
was that
was that safe
no it was not safe were you harmed maybe
not
right maybe you walked away got away
with scot-free but the point is you
didn't know and because you didn't know
it is by definition unsafe right
so
there's that and then there's this other
issue
like take the example of
what they did to the availability of
ibermectin right ivermectin became
almost impossible in the us at least to
get from a pharmacy
which meant
that they were taking
pharmacists and
they were getting between those
pharmacists and the doctors who were
writing their prescription which means
that they were not confident of their
ability to compel your doctor that it
didn't work
so if their point is it doesn't work and
that's why you can't have it
why are you
strong-arming my pharmacist and my
doctor right you should be able to
convince them they went to school for
this right and the point is if you can't
convince them that's not really my
problem all right you're telling me your
argument isn't any good you're telling
me in in myriad ways and
the only inference i can have is that
there's some reason you don't want me to
have this that isn't about it not
working right
that was the the implication i think
one of the one of the
things that upset me
quite early on was when when it was
explained to me that the emergency use
authorization was contingent upon there
being no other way to go
that you could only get
that emergency use authorization for
that kind of global rollout of something
brand new and untested
if it was the only option
you know if if the house is on fire
you just have to fight it with whatever
you've got
even if even if it's not the ideal thing
you know you fight it with whatever
you've got and that would that would
justify you doing some pretty extreme
things but but in the but in the case of
uh
cover 19
there were alternatives and if they had
acknowledged when someone explained to
me well if they acknowledge that there's
anything at all that's already available
that that will mitigate symptoms and all
the rest of it they can't get the
emergency authorization i thought well
well that's obvious then
this is this is clearly the explanation
for why
i ever met and became like trying to buy
you know crack cocaine yeah
yeah you know it was that unavailable
and it was that taboo
and i thought
once it was explained to me well they
can't allow that to be there because
otherwise they can't rule out the
vaccines
ivermectin pretty much free
vaccines very very expensive and
profitable
you don't need to be any kind of
scientist to do to join those two dots
together and work out what's happening
right i always wondered these people who
believe that this story made sense
let's suppose just hypothetically that
you had
a
a technology that might be worth
hundreds of billions of dollars
and what stands between you and those
hundreds of billions of dollars
is an out-of-patent drug that's so safe
that you can give it under conditions of
great uncertainty you don't even need to
know that the patient actually has the
disease it's safe enough to be cautious
and give it to them and give it to their
family because it has a prophylactic
effect if a drug you can't make any
money on that is produced all over the
world that has been given billions of
times
actually worked and that stands between
you and hundreds of billions of dollars
what will that conversation sound like
inside of big pharma well do we actually
expect that somebody would say well
you know gentlemen i hate to break it to
you but we have this amazing it's a
market that could open up for us it's a
huge new sector it could transform our
industry but
there is this lovely molecule and it
works so well that actually there's no
reason to deploy it do we imagine that
conversation happened
i can't imagine what it would sound like
so
i
i've
we've all gone we've all gone through
this
all the people that were in that room
yesterday have all gone through
that same
process
more or less
and i now feel
completely flame proof
from any continued attempt to persuade
me
by the by the techniques that i've been
being in play
the um the shouting at me the name
calling
the ridiculing and all the rest of it is
now absolutely powerless to have any
effect on me
it no longer matters what gets shouted
at me by those people what they call me
i am i have become somehow immune to it
and so going it's almost been cathartic
i've got to the other side of something
and being in that room yesterday and and
talking about the shared experience with
all those other people
think yes we've been through something
this has been a wholly unexpected
event that has affected
millions of people
and it's it's shoveled some people in
one direction and it's moved some people
in the other direction and and having
gone through that sorting process
has been revelatory
it's uh beautiful and important but i'm
going to argue there's a dimension of
this um
that isn't captured i mean i've got the
same feeling of course
um
and it's not the first time either
because of course you'll remember that i
came to public attention
uh at the
pointy end of a crowd
demanding my resignation over my
supposed racism
and so i've been accused of vile things
before and withstood it and gotten to
the other side and
the point is
everybody needs to have that experience
because until you know that there is
another side then
you will be controlled by what people
might say about you
the problem is that what people say
about us
still matters a great deal even if we
are individually immune to it yeah
granted and the the thing that i'm most
concerned about is that
this is really about something we have
to defeat the force that has captured
all of our institutions and turned them
to purposes that are not publicly
spirited
in order to do that we need to reach a
lot of people and
there is an attack that i have become
cognizant of that i think is still very
potent
and the attack it's i think it's an
extension of the fear uncertainty and
doubt tactic
but if you deliver if you say right if
somebody says look
brett weinstein
is obviously
not
a biologist in any meaningful sense what
what he says is so
transparently simple-minded and counter
to even the most
basic understanding of this that or the
other right if you deliver that kind of
slander
and then somebody who doesn't know
biology right or has a very narrow
textbook view of it perhaps
listens and they think
well i i don't really i don't spot
anything that's off about what he's
saying that sounds credible enough what
they've just done
is ask the question oh am i a simpleton
do i not understand biology myself
because i can't see through brett
right and so that trick
does not cause people to think that they
know that i or tess or any of the other
scientific experts who are speaking
about this are not making sense what it
causes them to do is say
i don't know what to make of this i
can't call it but i certainly don't want
to stand up and say actually you know
tests make sense to me and then be
mocked for what i don't understand so
i'll just
tune out and i think people are tuning
out
of
the thing they most need to hear because
basically the the opposition has a a
very powerful strategic weapon i do
think though that
more and more i know more and more
people are are
quietly at the moment
acknowledging that yes indeed something
is wrong
that that is leaking that is that is now
a leaky colander
the truth is gushing out now yes
and there's something
this has been such a an
existential event and experience that it
has come down i mean people write me
letters and they talk about light and
dark good and evil
right and wrong it's it's been it's been
distilled down to very basic stuff now
and what i take reassurance from is that
the truth will out i mean it's a cliche
this
whether it happens today or tomorrow or
i couldn't put a time scale on it but i
know the truth will out because that's
what the truth does
it is perennial as the grass it will
re-emerge from whatever is
laid upon it to to to
uh you to you to obfuscate to obliterate
it it will come back
so i i'm trusting that the truth will
work in our favor eventually it's become
that cut and dried for me it's become
that simple good and evil right and
wrong what's being done is wrong
and
wrong will not prevail
right will prevail
um i wish i shared your confidence i
think in a prior era that might be right
but the novelty of our era makes me
wonder about it
and i believe part of what you're saying
is certain and in fact the truth has
already emerged and there are many
people who are never going back into the
cave right who have simply seen it
but
the problem is
the thing that has captured all of our
institutions and i don't pretend to know
what it is i can
say something about its dimension based
on how it behaves and what it's
obviously capable of but i don't know
what it is and i don't know what it
wants that thing
has to be beaten it has to be defeated
because it is a reckless monster
right it is obviously capable with the
tools at its disposal of doing
tremendous harm to humanity or worse so
it has to be defeated and so the point
is the fact that the truth has emerged
that there are some of us who have
detected important elements of it and
that we are now in conversation is good
but we need enough power to marshal the
next argument and
when i began
looking at kovid
it started for me with the lab leak
right
i did not actually expect us to win that
argument right i did expect that we
would figure out
whether it had happened and i believe we
are essentially there
but i did not expect the public to
become aware that the wet market or some
other natural origin story just didn't
fly and yet it did and at the point that
that had happened my thought was well
the lab leak was a surprise win
you've got except it was it's we won
because it was true
that's my
it's it it couldn't the truth emerges
it
that's why that's why the public have
accepted broadly that it was a lab leak
now we don't yet know whether there was
any intent or just accident right but it
it that's its origin story it came out
of that building
having been tampered with you know that
and and the fact that that has emerged
and been accepted i think is is a point
on my on my school it is it is the truth
came out the truth came out and it
actually stuck right they did not manage
to muddle it enough that people don't
get it now they don't get the second
part of it right
i i feel like the lone voice saying
actually
it's not even true
that
the fact of it having emerged
may be effectively settled but
downstream of that it's just like it had
emerged naturally
the consequences of the protocols that
it will have been run through to produce
its capabilities are fundamentally
important to the disease that it causes
and to the way it spreads
and therefore
we are entitled to know how it was
created and if they will not tell us we
are entitled to put together a working
group of the best minds and reverse
engineer what must have been done so
that we can understand what this thing
is and
i can't i can't emphasize enough how
much rests on the question of what the
thing is what they were trying to
produce where they were in the process
what protocols were used what creatures
was it run through in the cereal
passaging what tissues was it run
through these are critical questions
from the point of view of knowing how to
control it
so
hopefully that level will emerge at some
point but i'm not confident it will
um but the
the other issues in the covid debacle
right the question of repurposed drugs
and early treatment and the question of
vaccine safety and effectiveness
were it true that the truth came out and
that the public came to understand it
the way it understands lab leak right
those three things together
then
once you've seen what happened there
tell you ah i can see the failure of
every layer of our system i can see the
failure of the journalists i can see the
role of the tech sector i can see the
failure of government i can see the
relationship between national
governments and these international
bodies i can see the gavi the trusted
news initiative all of these elements of
that failure would be made would be laid
bare
and were we to get to that moment
then the really important thing then
we'd have a party
well that would be that would be quite
the day it would be quite the day
because that would be that would that
would be
revelatory
in every sense in every
understanding of the work of the world
that would change the world
because like you and but for different
reasons that i just know that there's
something profoundly wrong across the
board
institutions have been captured
something is rotten in the state of
denmark i just know that
if that becomes
generally accepted and furthermore
explained and exposed
then that would
that would rearrange the building blocks
of
of society itself
and it's it would be it's no surprise
that that's why that's not going to
happen today and it's not going to
happen tomorrow it's it's so big
i think we're i think we're on i think
part of my my
smoldering anxiety every minute of every
day
is because i'm aware that
the the necessary
uh
sequence of events is so
profound it's a paradigm shift
and it's not just a paradigm shift it's
going to it's going to expose something
that has been going wrong presumably for
a very very long time and that's going
to be very difficult for everyone for
for both sides
in the war
there's no one is going to avoid
being hurt by that revelation
well i also
you know you say it will be revelatory
i think for those of us who are
aware of it it will be revelatory
because we've already grappled you know
and i think in your in your talk
yesterday you spoke about the grief
process and what role it plays in in the
discovery here those of us who have
already
gone through it
right will be
relieved that we can at least now
finally talk about the topic right wrong
at every level captured across the board
no functional institutions
for everybody else
that is going to be a terrifying moment
and it has to be i don't want them
terrified but we have to get through the
terrifying moment to get to the moment
where we get to discuss what we're going
to do about it right and to me
this isn't about covet and it was never
about covet covid reveals the problem
what i've learned though my what i the
reassurance i would offer people is that
the revelation it's difficult
but it's survivable it's yeah it's not
that bad you know the you know the
the greatest fear is fear itself you
know you know
we have become a society for example
that is is that is terrified of pain
physical pain because we have so many
means of
dealing preventing pain
and aesthetics and painkillers and all
the rest of it
there's some justification for thinking
you might get through your three score
and 10 without ever having an ouchie
because pain relief is so sophisticated
so people are terrified of pain
but
you know the reality you go back a
couple hundred years and people are
having legs amputated you know by saw
doctor right without anything and they
actually survived it and it and it's
arguably the case that they it hurt them
less because they just weren't as afraid
of the pain yep the pain still hurts
but being terrified of the
pain it
exacerbates the situation i think and i
think people have we've had a 70 years
since the
you know the last great global
conflagration
and there's an illusion that you can go
through your life without suffering
but when you realize that no you can't
there will be suffering
and the suffering is survivable
that's a moment
oh it's huge that you can you think well
the worst has happened and i'm still
here
i i thought it would make me cease to
exist
i thought it would be too much for me
but it's not and
the bit of the process that i've gone
through has that's been the revelation
from me i thought well
it's okay
it's it's a rotten thing to understand
it's a rotten thing to go through but
it's it's survivable here's the here's
the other side
well it's better than that um and i'm
gonna return us to what might be the
most important topic here
i have a
lifelong fascination with plato's cave
uh i think the story is important i
think it keeps returning to us in
modernized forms you know the matrix is
clearly plato's cave and the matrix
might actually add an element that plato
needed and it's not there right what
happens to the person who leaves plato's
cave when he returns
is
important for people to understand right
those inside the cave
don't want to know
those
out here in modernity who make the
discovery that you're talking about
i believe and i think you believe will
go through a terrifying grief process
you and i both know it's finite because
we've done it
on the other side of that not only is
there the relief of
having grappled with it and processed it
and still being functional and alive and
and all of that
but there is
a marvelous
group of people who have
gone through it too and effectively
you join that group at the point that
your eyes open and it's you know it's
like the nebuchadnezzar in in
in the matrix
so
you know i've been trying to figure out
how to convey this to people and and i
came up with this see what you think
it sucks
to be in a foxhole right it's no place
any rational person wants to find
themselves living
but the company in the foxhole is
incredible you will find the most
remarkable people in this foxhole and
you will
you're better off you will feel better
having the company of those people their
insight their calm right their sense of
humor than being stuck uh in
whatever the bunker is where it's all
lies and everybody's untrustworthy
because they're terrified they're going
to be slandered that they're going to be
accused of you know sitting down with
the wrong person or whatever the
accusations are
it's it's the captain scot thing it's
far better to die like this than in too
much comfort at home
you know and you know and shackleton you
know i'm big you know you're
talking about plato's cave and i'm one
of my sort of true norths is well
ironically
shackleton's south and when when you
know when it's that when because they
were doing something that was so
physically arduous and in many respects
they just wanted it to be over
but it
it showed them something about
themselves that they would not have
achieved
in any other way
and
it's there is a there is a great
there's a profound relief
in knowing that it is worth suffering
suffering is its own reward i'm not you
know you've got to be careful you know
we're not
we're talking about things are largely
psychological rather than rather than
physical but when you go through that
sort of i mean i've i felt as if i said
yesterday over the last couple i
realized that the world i thought i knew
had died and i was grieving for it
and i did grieve for it but i came out
of the other side of it
all through the you know the anger the
denial the bargaining the you know the
depression
i did come through it and
you think before that process begins
that you don't ever want to have that
you don't ever want to go through it but
it's better to have gone through it
it's enriching
and it's meant that you know the
encounters i was having yesterday with
with other people from all sorts of
walks of life and you know people i was
only going to spend these two minutes
with probably probably the only two
minutes i'm ever going to have with this
person and they were so intense
and it was all fueled by the fact that
they had gone
they had come to the same understanding
in their own way and i was standing
hugging
total strangers
and you think this is worth it
which aren't happened
but it's worth it right no it is worth
it and i'm sure you're having the same
experience that i am
of people saying
the most remarkable things to you
they'll stop you on the street and you
know
they'll look you in the eyes they want
you to understand what they're trying to
say and they will say things like
you are keeping me sane all the time
right it's it's an extraordinary
experience to go through that even once
yes
if it happened to you once in your life
once in your life yeah it would be
enough yeah but when it when people are
repeatedly saying
that the fact you know you've that
you've let it be known that you think
something and i realize that i think
that too and that means i'm not even if
i am mad
i'm not the only mad person there's at
least two of us right and but then you
real and that it ripples out
and
all these people
that's what i mean when i say it's
distilled down to fundamentals for me
the the fact that i'm in contact with
her i've been contacted by people from
new zealand yeah from the other side of
the planet and everywhere else in
between from every continent i've had
letters and communication from people
who've said you've worked you've gone to
all sorts of effort to get a message to
me to say i think that as well
and it means so much to me to know that
someone else thinks what i think
it's profound
it's been i'm a different i've been i've
been made a different person on account
of
covert 19. it's such an even that is i
don't know what covert 19 is i don't i
don't know what it's for i don't know
who did it and why
but it's it's a key that has unlocked
something for me
yeah it's it's beautiful and i will also
say there's another dimension i don't
know if you will have seen it but
um
so there's sort of two categories of of
people in
the dissident movement right there are
people who are recognizable you you and
me for example
and
then there are people who regard
themselves as anonymous and frequently
their first assumption is that they are
unimportant
right they will often introduce
themselves and they will not mention
their name and i will always say who are
you right because
that's not the way to think about it
you've just joined a small group of
people and
what what is this anonymity business
right
but
the number of
absolutely extraordinary people in that
anonymous group is amazing right i've
met some of the smartest people the most
capable people who show up just as a
person in a crowd at first and then it
becomes clear to you over a few
interactions oh wait a minute this is a
very special person right and anyway
some of these people have become close
friends and and allies in the sense that
you know when that term used to have a
real meaning uh and that's delightful
too just it's like i when i used to walk
into a classroom the first time you know
that i met my class at the beginning of
the year
i would look out at the sea of faces and
i would think
there are people in here that you know
nine months from now i'm going to
realize just the depth of what's going
on in their minds and it will be it will
be a beautiful thing to know them but i
don't know who they are yet you know and
it's that thing that just the like a sea
of human discovery is now available
because this thing has forced
very unique people together and anyway
it's a joy do you think do you think
there's a there's
is there precedent for this
when you look back in history yeah
do you think or as a scientist and you
look at
i don't know leaps of understanding or
has there been anything like this before
a great deceit or a great concept or a
great
has anything been done like this before
or has it simply not been possible
before
i want to answer that with
i think it's a yes and no okay i think
there are a thousand precedents every
piece of this has happened somewhere
with ex with the exception of something
highly technical
but the sum total of what has happened
here i'm pretty sure is is novel
and
you know i said at the beginning of
covid i don't know if i set it into a
camera but i think i did
this is the biggest thing that's ever
happened
and i meant that and i was you know i
wasn't forgetting about world wars or
anything like it but there was something
about this that it really truly was
global right it's even a world war there
are places it doesn't touch right
this
was
a uniting a potentially galvanizing
moment across the entire globe and of
course something interrupted that
galvanizing process
but
the way in which whatever has happened
on the far side of that has put us
together has created a global
conversation
it has burned out
many of the tools that
whatever that antagonistic force is
their best tools
are evaporating on them right they have
called attention there are too many
people aware of the tricks
um and
you know some people will hover at the
edge and maybe they'll go back to
imagining the world as normal but a lot
of people won't so
i think the answer is no i think this is
the net the net outgrowth here is
unprecedented
it's interesting to me that
what made a lot of it possible to
if this was if you know if there was a
cabal that decided to this is the time
to press the button it was the internet
that made it possible
you know for example the whole working
from home
you know everyone being able to retreat
to their to their hutches and be
isolated one from another
ordering food ordering everything that
you wanted you know
for a lot of people it was possible for
the first time
and i ironically or paradoxically
this the seeds of that i'm doing are in
the tool that made it possible because
the internet also made it possible for
all of us
to reach out to each other
they were able to bring the internet to
bear
as a as part of how they were able to
get us all organized in the way that
they wanted as organised but the
internet is also has also freed us
it's it's so something it's been there's
a bug in the system that they weren't
aware of and it's their undoing
they thought they could do they thought
the internet is here we can do it now
let's go
but within the internet has been the
seeds of their undoing i think that is
the way in which we've been able to mine
information share information
circulate around the globe get it into
each other's hands
and that'll be their undoing
so i'll i'll
try to do it quickly but
i have a model for this
there is a
ratio of
conspiracy
that goes into whatever has happened and
then there's emergent
phenomena that aren't conspiratorial
they're not conscious
we don't know what the admixture is
right but it's some frag you know is
there conspiracy involved here well you
know yeah you've got big pharma and
fiduciary responsibility which is
another way of saying that there's a
conspiracy of people trying to do
something in their interests which are
which consider our interests unimportant
so yeah there's some conspiracy
but here's the thing
the emergent part
is effectively we can
uh
we can call that it's it's an evolved
product it's a it's an adaptive product
of evolution in the very real sense
now here's the here's the important part
to the extent that part of what we are
up against is an emergent property and
not a conscious group of people who
think about how to outfox us that thing
will have a couple of characteristics
one it will be ferociously powerful
right
but it will be stupid about anything it
hasn't seen before right the fact of it
being a product of evolution tells you
it will be good inside the zone that it
that built it and it will be a [ __ ]
when it runs up against things that it
hasn't encountered
now that is what you're talking about so
i keep on thinking about
sheldon cooper character and big bang
theory
the big brain you know he's this
the the pre the premise is that it's the
four cleverest guys in california all
shadow all live together
and they have they have a they have
their understanding of the world and
sheldon cooper is a kind of autistic
savant
and he's incredibly smart
he's a genius level individual
but he's continually outsmarted and
undone by the woman who lives across the
hall from them
she's just a regular joe regular jane
but she's got human empathies
and
street smarts and other characteristics
that he simply cannot ever allow for
because he's never felt them
and that his undoing every time so this
it's like the world's being taken over
by
by by someone who lacks
something crucial
there's a crucial absence and that is
what's going to bring them down they're
not allowing for
humanity
humanity is an extraordinary
event
we've been here for 200 300 000 years as
homo sapiens and we've been here for
millions of years as
as variations on the same theme
and
it's not by accident that we've lasted
this long
and we've got all sorts of innate
characteristics the human animal isn't
it everyone's excited about artificial
intelligence and all the rest of it but
the flesh and blood and bone human
animal
is
the most extraordinary thing that the
universe has ever seen
and to and you can't outwit it
and
something that lacks
that empathic connection to humanity
is trying to run humanity
and it doesn't
fundamentally understand the animal that
it's trying to control
and that's why the animal will get away
from it
we will get away from them because they
don't understand us and they don't
really appreciate what we're capable of
i
quite agree with this but i want to
point out the
the bitter pill at the end of that
beautiful argument
the number of people
who when actually when the chips are
down
um we'll look at this particular hill
and say you know what
yeah
i'll die on that one which doesn't mean
i'm looking to die on that hill but it
means i'm willing to if i have to the
hill is that important right
the number of people who will do that is
surprisingly high and this is one of
these characteristics about human beings
that you're talking about it is not
intuited by people who are monsters
because they wouldn't there's no hill
they'll die on because they don't
believe that deeply in things they're
about something much more mundane
so that's good news for us because that
means that there are a lot of people who
if we can reach them will join us and
we'll be courageous about it
the problem is it's an arms race because
even those of us who will look at a
particular hill and say you know what
that one's important enough right
even those of us who will do that
there are things
that frighten us
right this is why torture has returned
to the west right the west swore off
torture it understood it to be
fundamentally wrong
right it's actually written into the
american constitution that it is wrong
but the west has returned to torture
because it it provides a tool if you're
if your toolkit is inadequate to control
people because there are too many people
who will die on that hill to prevent you
from doing it then you have to innovate
fates worse than death
right
and there are fates worse than death so
we are in an arms race my friend and
the enemy
has no decency
so no
i wonder if they've got the
i wonder if they have them the
i've said i've thought this before
that
the terrible things that were done
the horrible and unforgivable of the
20th century
was was perpetrated and then committed
by
by by generations who had
seen and done terrible things
you know the the the the survivors of
the first world war
then became active in the second world
war and then then you get into the
second half of the 20th century in which
all sorts of the gulags and all the rest
of the you know the horrible was up was
a progression but it was being done by
people who had been to some extent
brutalized or jet some generations that
had been brutalized
it takes quite a lot of doing to commit
the horrible
if you've lived in a world of essential
peace
i i have my doubts
that those who seem to be running the
show now
have the
of the bottle
to
commit to to set themselves to the
necessary wet work
that you're describing that is
that is a new thought to me and it's a
beautiful one
and it also
rings a bit true i hope you're right
i don't think they've got it in them
because they are not they have they like
the rest of us in the west have mostly
grown up in a time of peace
and they haven't seen and done
that which had been seen and done by
previous generations that
unknowingly brutalized
either stood silent while other things
were done or actively participated in
them
there aren't any people who are the
product of that alive at the moment
and i don't think they've got to end
them to do
what would have to be done when enough
people
the last time the horrible was committed
there were only one and a half to two
billion people on the planet there's no
eight yeah that's a big lump of
butchered meat
if you decided that you were gonna get
stuck into it
i don't think they've got it in them i
think when push comes to shove they'll
back off because they haven't got it in
them
well they won't back off but i
i like i like your model here it rings
rings true what i think we have seen
already
is that
just as your model predicts they will be
capable of the most spectacular
indifference to human suffering but
that's different than what you're
calling the wet work
right
the willingness
to
uh to demonize a drug that would help
people who are
dying alone in hospitals because their
family is forbidden to enter right
the callousness of that is
jaw-dropping
but it's not the same thing
as ushering somebody into a gas chamber
no
no that is my that is my point oh that's
my hope yeah
no i like it i i
i'm going to be thinking about that for
a good long time and comparing it to
everything i know and that i see and
trying to figure out
you know how thick that ice is because
hey if it's true
it actually
tells us something about about the beast
that we're fighting that's useful that's
actually operationalizable
and i hope you're right and frankly
i hope if they're listening
that they understand what's being
discussed because
whether they know it or not
they're depending on us succeeding
right their mechanism for governing this
planet is absolutely reckless and there
is no way that the planet
can survive it right they are not good
at managing complex systems and that's
one thing when you don't have extremely
powerful tools and so your errors are
limited in their scope but the tools are
getting more powerful right this is not
going to be a long ride if you don't get
some very careful thinkers into those
roles
so you know to the extent that these
people these people who are behaving so
monstrously have children and
grandchildren that they want to deliver
a world to
they ought to wake up and figure out you
know
who it is that they would trust this
place to because they can't do it agreed
so there are a couple um
i think when when i started this
conversation i was so eager to talk to
you about substance that i didn't say
much about who you are and uh
what you do and this is worth adding in
here
um you i know now that you trained as an
archaeologist
i know that is it your first book
uh is the wisdom of the ancient sciences
that's my first i've got about i think
i've lost count now 10 10 10 10 books
out there with my name on them yes all
right well that's a lot of reading that
i have to do but uh all right so um and
you have a current book a new book i do
i do i have a book called uh the story
of the world in 100 moments
i i try
i
i'm i'm a generalist you describe
yourself you said
an evolutionary biologist with a
generalist i'm a generalist of another
thought of another sort
i've always just loved the storytelling
of history
i'm not a historian i am an
archaeologist but it's the it's the
stories
it's the tales of daring do
it's the it's the aspiration it's the
triumph and disaster of it i love the i
love the kind of round the campfire
recounting of of great deeds
and that i try to emulate that in this
in sort of boots so the light it's light
light history i suppose i'm not you know
i'm not i've produced a book called the
story of the world in 100 moments
and it's it's not a textbook it's not
supposed to it's not supposed to
teach people the history of the world
it's it's to it's maybe to encourage
people to think about what they think
are the most significant moments spread
across the the four or five thousand
years of recorded history the things
that
each one of us is an individual and and
a different set of lights come on for
each of us
our eyes are if we if you looked up at
the night sky and you hadn't understood
the constellations as they've been
perceived we would all make our own
patterns out of the night sky
and so i'm i'm suggesting that
that history is is all the lights in the
universe what patterns do you make
what does your what does your eye give
you when you look up at that confusing
spectacle of light
and so some of it you know there are
events in the story of the world in 100
moments that are maybe things that
people would expect and others are are
tiny moments that just resonate
that just resonate for me but it's the
it's always been about the the
storytelling for me i just think i i
enjoy another fantasy that i had for the
book i i'd long thought wouldn't be
great if as a party trick you could
stand up in 10 minutes tell the story of
the world
if you could distill all of it down into
something meaningful that could be
recited memorized
what a great trick that would be so the
book's partly a product of that i'm i'm
fascinated by the way in which certain
stories have have lasted for thousands
of years
why
you know we've still got the epic of
gilgamesh
it's still with us
we've still got the stories of the old
testament they're still there i mean
well
they've come down to the to the present
day because they they are the
distillation of wisdom
and they've become shorter
they've been compressed out of the great
heap of of coal has been compressed
diamonds
and
you have to ask yourself why are we
still telling ourselves some of these
very old stories well in part the answer
is because they're true or they have
truth in them
and i love that i love i love stories
so i call this metaphorical truth
um and my definition is metaphorically
true things are things that
you are
at advantage if you believe them as if
they are true rather than recognize that
they are not exactly true
and
i also say you cannot write a myth
right you can write a story and then
evolution will either favor it
alter it
distill it and turn it into a durable
myth or it won't but the point is you
can't you can't write it that way it's
selection that does that right it's the
great stories that get
um
refined in this way
uh i must say though there's a you know
it's characteristic of you uh
to be so
modest about it but when you say well
it's not a textbook you know it's light
you're describing
the craft of delivering this very potent
thing in a way that it doesn't feel like
medicine
right and so i i esteem this at the
highest level this is what somebody who
is truly good at conveying something
deep will do is they will deliver it in
a way that you don't even realize you're
transformed by it right and so anyway
i'm looking forward to reading this book
i love i i love the way that as well
that
um
i'm i'm i'm quietly obsessed with for
example say the cave art from 30
thousand years ago last school month
and so on because there's a there must
be a storytelling in that as well
that the creation of of those tableau of
animals and
who knows
they will serve many functions but there
must have been a storytelling
aspect with within it and that they are
still as have the power to move us
in our 21st century world i mean i defy
anyone to look at
some of that cave art and not have a
have the hackles
rise
there's some things you know
picasso said after altamira all his
decadence
acknowledging that something had been
achieved then by those shadows
those lost people
that has never been better not by
michelangelo not by him
not by leonardo
there's something so
potent
in in in
and that and that those people
30 000 years ago in in worlds
unimaginably different from ours
in circumstances living day-to-day in
circumstances that we cannot conceive of
they still set aside time
for
that kind of creation they crawled into
the darkness
deep underground
with little lamps in their hands little
animal fat and tallow lamps
and found these
contours on rock that suggested to them
that there was something there that
ought to be brought to the surface
like sculptors say that the thing is
already in the rock and it just has to
be released they were looking at the
contours of the rock illuminated by
shadowy light and then like you know
like like someone with with a you know
fly fishing you know they were drawing
trying to lure the bear or lure the
bison to to come further forward out of
the rock and when they glimpsed it they
just put a line on it
there's its shoulder there's the flank
and that's enough
we've we've
done it and they will withdraw
and they walk and they walk to in the
darkness fell on it maybe forever
that they that those people living those
lives at that time set aside some of
their every fire had to be kindled every
morsel of food had to be found or hunted
and yet they were still
making time to do these extraordinary
things
deep underground in the dark
and we are still moved by them now
because what they did was true and it
mattered and we can feel it
all right
at the risk of being the scientist who
can't help himself but to pull apart the
flower
um
i want to
i want to take a look at what you've
just described from a slightly different
angle
imagine for a second that you have a
compulsion
if i know
that
ancestors
made the effort that you've described
which is not a small effort to leave
these renderings on these cave walls all
right
i know they did it for a reason and that
that reason has to be
something other it has to it has to
improve their well-being their fitness
in some way
and i think what it is
my hypothesis for this would be
that these pictures transport
information through time vital
information and i can imagine let's you
know if you have effectively
hunter-gatherers who are nomadic who are
following creatures that are huntable
right that you would imagine that a
population
would ebb and flow into a valley and it
might be
generations between contacts with a
particular location right imagine that
your ancestors left you a treasure map
in a cave so that when you arrived in
this valley you had some idea what the
passage of the seasons would bring right
what is this place is it is it okay or
is it not okay right that kind of
information
right and then this actually really is
the same thing as what we call art right
because what art does
is it takes things that we need to know
and i don't necessarily mean that
analytically but things that we need to
know you know guernica
it can sit dormant on the wall and you
can marvel at the you know the insight
of picasso and the strange mind that he
had to be able to convey this thing with
those odd shapes right
but then at some point somebody starts
dropping [ __ ] bombs on somebody else
and it's like guernica got it right
that reminder from somebody who saw
something who figured out a way to
transport it across time to you even
though they wouldn't be there to explain
it right that's a really important
process right orwell is back right
that's important now here's the thing
though
let's go
that cave
right
one interpretation is that the message
on that cave wall is no longer relevant
because we are not hunter-gatherers and
so the populations of
huntable beasts are irrelevant to us
okay true
on the other hand
imagine that this creature distantly
related to us
not so distantly but distantly in our
time scale
was telling us something about what we
are and that it is again relevant right
because we have we have come
so far from that and yet as you point
out it's the basic human characteristics
that are still going to make the
difference
yes i do i i i agree with all of that i
just i marvel at our modern response to
something that comes from another world
we
it
enables us to reach through 30 000 years
and
momentarily i have a moment of i have a
moment of connection
with people that that shuffled over the
hill into the invisible
eons
you know the the thing that they left
behind still affects us
you know that we're still running hunter
software
but although we live these sophisticated
lives we are at heart
the animal that we've always been
and a glance at the artwork of of lascal
reminds us
that
we are the same
and we know we're the same because we
look at those pictures created by them
then and we are moved by them
whatever they mean
whatever was the motivation for creating
those works it moves us
and i think you're right we we
definitely have i think part of
part of
what has been exploited is being
exploited this very moment by those who
who don't have our best interests at
heart to put it mildly
have lost connection with
humanity
they've lost
that sense of awe
you know we we insulate ourselves from
pain we insulate ourselves from dying
and death we put it out of sight we
don't involve ourselves with it we don't
want to see it we don't want to smell it
we don't want to be confronted by it and
we are the less because of that
we're there's a growing distance
from the flesh and blood of humanity
and we you know we must reclaim it we
must remind ourselves of it
and
looking back at the for example
at those ancient words i think is is
helpful and it's therapeutic because
just to be reminded of what a wonder the
human animal is
must never be forgotten
and and part of what is being done now
is being done by people who have
forgotten
how special we are this this
thirsting lusting towards artificial
intelligence and
and and uh
transhumanism and all the rest of it
hold on
you know before you do all that
let's let's remember just what we are
what we've been capable of what we're
still capable of
and then we'll treat each other with
more dignity and more decency
so
there's a
problem with our design
which is
it is built around a practical scope
in other words your perception and your
cognition were built in an ancient
environment in which it there was no
point in thinking beyond yourself
past a certain threshold because there
was something you could do about it and
so from the point of view of enhancing
your fitness keeping an eye on a couple
of generations out was about the most
that was worth doing and any effort you
spent thinking about the distant future
was wasted for example because you
didn't have any power or influence over
it
that's not true anymore and in some
sense what i'm what i'm getting from
your description is
30 000 years ago
creatures stood in a cave and invested
in something that reaches us now and
reaches us in an important way it's not
trivial
and
a
imagine what you would have to do that
anything that you left behind on earth
was meaningful to anyone thirty thousand
years in the future
almost impossible to imagine what you
could do that would meet that challenge
also likely there will be no one here in
30 000 years right we'll be lucky to get
through the next 200.
so
that should be alarming to us right
relatives from 30 000 years ago did
something that's meaningful to us today
and we can already see that our time
horizon doesn't extend that far into the
future alarm bells should be going off
but we're not built to register them
because we have this narrow scope about
only a generation or two ahead and this
ought to be
recalibrating that sense about what's
important because in some sense think
about all the people who will never be
if we cease to exist in the next couple
hundred years or a thousand years all
the people who will never get to
experience this who might otherwise have
what right is it of ours to deny that to
them
aren't we obligated to deliver it oh yes
and what the mervin peak line about to
live at all is miracle enough
but i think we're
i have i've had a growing sense that we
are
we are
lacking a sense of awe
i think that's the best way i can
describe it
we're not awestruck by
each other
and we should be
and we're almost embarrassed about it
and
we live in these
these pixelated digitized
worlds where we look at each other
through screens so there's literally a
distance
between us
and it's becoming easier and easier to
live like that you could live inside
your house on your own have everything
delivered to your door and communicate
with with people but you're not really
you're not really communicating with
people what i got from being in that
conference hall yesterday was
fundamental because it was being in a
room with hundreds of
fellow human beings
and there's nothing quite like it you
when you say something on the stage you
know instantly if it's registered or if
it's had any effect on even one person
or on the collective
it's an amazing feeling
and if we forget
how
important how
energizing and enriching is just to be
in a room with people
in the analog and not the digital
we need to reclaim a sense of oh
we do and
you know this is actually this is one of
the the real perks of uh
of my line of work because it does allow
you to see
if you do it right
that the miracles are literally
everywhere you and i at this moment are
engaged in an utterly miraculous process
right i am literally
vibrating air molecules in order to put
a thought in your head and i can have
reasonable confidence that if i do that
well you will actually have an idea that
bears resemblance to the one that i
meant to throw at you at this distance
right that's a miracle
in the windowsill
there might be a house fly
have you ever looked at a house fly
even that house fly is a miracle right
you know let alone a hummingbird or
something even more marvelous
they're everywhere and you know you're
right i like your focus
and i agree with you that
in that
grand sea of miracles human beings are
the most remarkable product of the
universe that we know it's the most
remarkable one that we've seen
all right
neil would you like to wrap us up
because i think we are yeah
how do i how do i do that well i don't
know you tell us what we need to know
and then we will revisit this at some
future point
i wish
the the
the the last two years had not happened
in in the events that i've unfolded i
wish i wish it were different
but but here we are
but i also value the experience beyond
price
and i'm aware that by saying this it
begins to sound ridiculous
and but it only doesn't sound ridiculous
if you've if you've gone through
if you've gone through the process
having my
uh
having obviously been sleepwalking and
being blissfully unaware for i don't
know how long
about the true texture of our reality
and having been snapped into a certain
awareness
of it having suddenly seen off as though
from a different perspective
or a different bit of high ground
it's i feel i have added to the store of
my
wisdom
something that is beyond price
so while
in so many ways i wish that
this hadn't happened it having happened
has made me
a better person
that's really all i can say
i am i would rather be the person that i
am now than the person that i was before
and the and the collateral benefit is it
has brought me into contact with people
like you and and others that were in
that room and i and i i value that some
accident some unexpected sequence of
events has has brought me into contact
with those people
and
so i'm glad
that that's happened and i've i'm glad i
think i'm beginning to understand what i
now understand
i agree it's been transcendent and i
must say the uh
the beauty of being able to sit with
somebody that i i will just confess i
find utterly delightful and i know that
that is a widely shared belief because i
heard
25 people say it at this conference in
separate contexts who weren't talking to
each other
uh we love you and
keep fighting i mean that means more to
me than i can see brett all right well
this has been a pleasure it has been a
pleasure thank you so much thank you